Have you ever really wanted a beer,...
...but you don't wanna stop working?
At Willow Garage, we've solved this problem.
We built a Web interface that has a menu of a number of different beers that you can select from.
Once you select the beer of your choice, you can place it in the "beer bucket"...
...and then, select the location of your choice for the robot to drive to.
Once those two things are completed, you simply click the big "beer me" button...
...and the robot comes to you to deliver your beer.
In this process, the robot goes to the fridge,...
...detects the handle of the fridge and opens it,...
...looks inside of the fridge and uses its cameras to detect what kinds of beers are available.
If the beers you've selected are not available,...
...the robot will inform you that your choice is not available at this time.
Otherwise, the robot picks the beers that you've selected from the fridge,...
...puts them in the cup holders mounted on its base and delivers them to the location that you've selected.